hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
I'm a professional podcaster named Conan
O'Brien
I've been doing this for a number of
years and I'm I'm a real real Pro oh boy
I'm the gold standard by which everybody
has judged now
sitting here with Sona Sona wouldn't you
call me the gold standard no I wouldn't
call you the gold standard I think
there's people who've done it longer
than you and much better uh yeah much
better I think you're good okay I think
you're fine okay I think you're okay I
have a story
um about the phrase the gold standard
that involves the great Johnny Carson oh
yeah I had the privilege of getting to
meet him a couple of times and talk to
him on the phone a few times and I
remembered once I was hosting some
special in the history of NBC on late
night I think 50 years and so I I got
the chance to uh with my my staff we cut
together these montages of every late
night NBC hosts cut together all of
their best stuff so Letterman Jack Parr
everybody Steve Allen I got to reach out
and contact them and send them their
stuff Letterman from his uh yeah late
night show and of course Johnny Carson
and then I got a call this is before
email I think thought I'd just get a
message that Johnny Carson either
approved or didn't and then I get this
call and they say Johnny Carson's on the
line for you and of course my soul left
my I mean it was just the you know he's
the biggest star in the world all the
time I was growing up and informed
everybody's idea of what a late night
show was so I saw the blinking light and
I was like that blinking light is Johnny
Carson and someone said no that's the
light that tells you he's on the phone
but anyway I picked up the phone and I
hit the button and there's you know his
famous voice and he more or less was
telling me that he watched the Montage
and he he thought it was good he thought
we did a good job and he really liked it
and and in the special I refer to him as
the gold standard I said of course
Johnny Carson the gold standard and he
said my my only I don't really do a
Carson impression but he said something
he said well uh the only thing I'll take
exception to is uh you referred to me as
the gold standard kind of a
self-deprecating thing that's the only
thing I'd disagree with you called me
the salt like a little much she called
me the gold standard and I said we'll
keep in uh keep in mind Johnny that gold
has been greatly valued and
I got a little chuckle I'm not going to
say I got a huge laugh but I got a
little chuckle and I was so happy that's
so cool yeah yeah what else do you guys
talk about he then started going on and
on about what a huge fan he was of mine
he didn't no he we actually had a really
uh nice conversation it wasn't that long
I don't like to over represent things
but it was really special I I got to
tell him that one of my favorite old
Carson Clips was he used to do this
character art firm oh yeah and art Fern
had this famous thing where he was like
a fast talking pitch man kind of and he
was telling you how to go someplace in
LA to buy a certain product and I was
telling Johnny Carson this I said oh my
God every time my writers see this
segment of art Fern that we show with
this with this line in it we die
laughing and so I I said it's the one
where your art Fern and you're saying do
this get on the 101 then switch to the
134 then get on the fire freeway and
then he says take the Slauson cut off
and he says then get out of your car and
cut off your Slawson and my writers
and he says and it's the way he could
rides up on his toes a little bit and he
goes he says take the slots and cut off
get out of your car cut off your Slauson
and he's got this big pointer he keeps
hitting the board with and my writers
and I we like to think that we're edgy
young hot shots we just watch that clip
and every time he does that joke we
burst out laughing it's Timeless when
you brought up art Fern I almost said
cut off your slots cut off your
I'm glad I didn't and I'm glad you
didn't also and I said that joke is
funny every time it was kind of just a
nice woman because he said yeah he said
it it is he said he kind of chuckled and
he went I don't know why
and then you know the conversation was
was over pretty quickly but it was just
really nice to be able to to tell him
you know how much uh he meant to all
these Young Writers still you know this
is years and years after he retired so
that was nice that's really nice I have
that memory until I lose it Slauson is
penis yes oh okay in this case yes it's
a street I wish you know what oh yes I
know the street yeah I I think Johnny
would have loved it had you been on set
he would have loved it because he loved
people like you so I'm not even kidding
no no no I'm serious if you had been on
set he would have loved if he'd said get
out of your car cut off your Slauson and
if he would said wait a minute is Sloss
and penis now of course that would have
shut down the network in 1974 but still
I wonder when he would have thought that
was really funny oh it was when Saturday
Night Live did that sketch of the nudist
sketch wasn't it that was the first time
you were allowed to and I worked on that
sketch well what do you talk about yeah
you're you're a peanut uh Pioneer yeah
in that sense Robert Smigel uh it was he
was the lead person on that sketch but I
worked on that sketch with him and wrote
a song at the end the penis song
standards came in I think it was
actually the great Rick Ludwin and they
just said there's no way you can do this
and we were arguing that like it's part
of the anatomy you should be able to say
penis of course now it seems like the
most tame thing in the world but you get
weird when people say vagina so you
would do that oh okay so sensor vagina
yeah oh God please
no
we gotta just shut that down I had no
idea you were the penis guy well
first of all you should know that I know
you are quite a reputation
of course my gnome to poop
to poop but also in in some parts of
Europe I'm known as the penis man
everyone calls me something different